lady gaga was born to be a star
she ranks number 87 on our world's
highest paid celebrities list
and number 97 on our richest self-made
women list
at 34 the singer songwriter actress and
businesswoman
has a net worth of 150 million dollars
lady gaga skyrocketed onto pop music
charts in 2008
with her hit just dance with empowering
lyrics and resonating messages of
acceptance
albums the fame and born this way topped
the charts and created loyal little
monsters
everywhere
her latest record chromatica is her
sixth number one album
[Music]
the queen monster has won 11 grammys
released six studio albums
and reached legendary status as a
performer like she knew she would
born stephanie germanotta in new york
city gaga was essentially music prodigy
learning to play the piano at age four
and performing open mic nights by 14.
she's classically trained in jazz and a
killer songwriter
but it wasn't always easy growing up
gaga dealt with bullying and says it has
stuck with her
but being told she'd never make it only
fueled her fire
at 19 gaga dropped out of nyu to pursue
music full time
and a year later she was signed but then
quickly dropped by def jam records
then walked in acon yes that acon
he signed her to his label imprint at
interscope records
and so it all began lady gaga's source
of wealth includes album sales
song royalties and ticket sales she's
reportedly earned
728 thousand dollars in royalties from
poker face
the monster's ball tour reportedly
grossed over 225 million dollars
despite gaga finding out afterward that
she was in debt three million dollars
due to the show's many lavish costumes
her shortened born this way ball tour
reportedly grossed over 180 million
dollars
she's cashed in on brand deals such as
versace
google chrome polaroid virgin mobile and
mac cosmetics
as well as her own perfume fame her real
estate holdings include a malibu mansion
worth 23 million dollars and frank
zappa's former hollywood home
she purchased for five and a quarter
million
moving to the big screen gaga landed a
leading role alongside bradley cooper in
the film a star is born
the film grossed 100 million dollars in
the box office in less than two weeks
after its premiere
and she earned an academy award for best
original song
[Music]
expanding her empire in 2019 gaga
launched her makeup line
house laboratories which raised over 10
million dollars in venture funds
and is sold exclusively on amazon that
same year
she began her las vegas residency
reportedly earning a million dollars per
show
nearly double previous earnings of vegas
residents britney spears
and celine dion underneath the eclectic
costumes and extravagant shows
is a performer skilled in reinvention
and resilience
we expect to continue seeing her climb
the charts as well as our list
after all there are still boundaries to
push in a way that only this star can